[Music]
all right let's go to michael in
shreveport what's up michael
hey dr john how are you i'm all right
man what's going on
so um i have a question so
how do i um bring out more confidence
and comfort from my girlfriend's parents
who seem to be a little overprotective
and a bit controlling
like is there something i can do or is
it just gonna take time um
i'm gonna go just a little bit into my
situation i don't want to take up too
much time explaining everything but both
of us are 21 years old
we've been together for
about six months very strong
relationship she's a phenomenal person
all around um and the parents are a
little involved in a relationship um
you know what's that mean every time we
it's something i'm sorry what's that
what does that mean that they're they're
kind of involved
so she tells her anything uh she
tells them everything we do everything
we talk about um
sometimes when we uh go out to say
dinner or something they'll come along
um they're phenomenal people very
respectful
respectable very hard working loving but
sometimes they get a little you know
restrictive on the time we spend
outside of say school we spend a lot of
time
on campus and all
is there just something i can do to gain
a relationship with her parents without
ruining the family dynamics like how can
i get more trust out of them to where
they'll allow her to spend more time
with me
oh man um it's a great question dude um
there's a lot going on here
um
they sound
pretty amashed for having a 21 year old
right i agree um
now it's not weird that they go out to
dinner with you and all that kind of
stuff but
it's weird that they're
i don't know my parents didn't have that
level of of
control over my time when i was 21
or 20 or 19.
yeah and
it turns out it's not just me
there are times when she'll tell me you
know
they won't even let her spend time with
her best friend um and they she even
does she live at home
uh yes she does um okay so here's the
thing you are you're dating a child
okay and i want you to think of it that
way
she has been alive 21 years old i mean
21 years but she's a child
and she's
acting like one and she's being treated
like one
and so
you feel like this is a grown-up
relationship because of your age and
it's not and so if you're okay dating a
high school kid
and then you're gonna live by those
rules and so be it
um
she's gonna have to decide this has
nothing to do with her parents that's
just the dynamic they've set up she's
gonna have to decide i'm a grown-up and
i'm gonna spend time with who i wanna
spend time with and i'm gonna begin to
develop boundaries between me and my
parents
and that might mean i gotta get my own
place and pay my own rent that might
mean i got to get my own place pay my
own rent and then i'm going to have to
pay tuition because my parents are
immature and they're going to cut me off
or they may have been trying to kick her
out for years and she's whatever you
know you know what i mean so this issue
is less with their parents and more with
her
what is it about her
that is
worth
having a high school dating relationship
again
we've just been knowing each other for a
long time and um
i've just been praying
like for years for somebody to enter my
life and i feel you know a great
connection with her we get along
extremely well
we talk every day you know it's just
overall a great relationship with a
great person and she's just so worth
keeping and fighting for in my mind
okay
um
i'm gonna strongly recommend you don't
go to war with her parents you'll lose
oh everybody
i do not want to ruin the family
dynamics and that's why i'm you know
well you don't you don't have that power
quite honestly right
you're not strong enough to ruin this
family dynamic i can see you all getting
married and then in five years
when she her mom is still in the middle
of y'all's life and you have one kid
another one on the way that you snap
and say this is our house not their
house this is our marriage
our sexuality our parenting our life not
theirs
and that's what you're gonna be dealing
with in two years and five years and 10
years and 20 years if y'all don't have
boundary discussions now
right
and i'll tell you this man i got a lot
of a lot a lot of great great great
friends great friends men and women
i couldn't marry them
you know what i mean and they bring a
lot of really wonderful things to my
life but we're not married
and what i'm telling you is you're in
for a long haul with this relationship
oh i i kind of went in knowing that okay
but um you know i i just you know in my
mind it's just worth it for her
because here's what they're doing just
so
they are not
they are still parenting her as though
she's a child
yes and so they have autonomy over her
time in her space and her physical
presence
probably what she says
um
inviting themselves to think do they pay
for a lot of stuff
um
you talking about her parents right
um
i'm not are you talking about like our
her life or when we go out and do
something both
um
to be honest she does pay her own bills
like under her house she does pay you
know her insurance and she has a
loan for uh college and all she pays for
herself in fact she has a job and she
runs her own business out of her house
um and when
we go out and do stuff you know i always
take care of myself and her okay so when
you have you asked her about her
enmeshment have you said hey
it seems weird that you're 21 and your
parents are still restricting your time
like this
um i haven't brought that up but she has
said um you know
every now and then when we talk she has
that you know
this has been in the back of my mind i
kind of want to find a higher paying job
and move out
um
but at the same time you know she's
almost done with college and she's about
to go to culinary school and she plans
on staying at home for culinary school
okay so here's an important part of of
relationships anyone like this that you
see any kind of future with
is no secrets
tell the truth
the good stuff and the tough stuff
now you can weaponize this you can
weaponize truth
and what i mean by that is instead of
saying
um when somebody asks you hey do i look
good in this be like
that's not my favorite shirt
or you wore something last week that was
great that's different than oh my gosh
you look like a beach toy i mean you can
say you can be abusive with truth right
right um
but you can also be honest
this is a moment for your young
relationship
two young people in a young relationship
where you can be honest
right
so man your parents are around a lot i
would love to see us move into a
situation where
they have less control over
us over me over you
um what would it look like for you to
get your own place when you're in
culinary school
and
what would that look like for us to not
bring them on dates with us anymore
whatever that looks like you know what i
mean it can be any number of things but
you need to have that conversation
because it's weighing on you
and i tell you to have this conversation
if about any number of other things the
other six months in and if this one
conversation here is really important
okay so hear me closer michael
if you are nervous to have this one
conversation
because you're afraid it might hurt the
relationship it might end the
relationship
i'm gonna tell you this relationship
ends at some point
it ends
more catastrophically than it would now
if you already aren't having hard
conversations aren't telling the truth
or holding a little bit of secrets here
and a little bit of secret zero or
you're frustrated and you clench your
fist and you're not seeing it six months
in
that does not bode well for the future
of this thing
and she may be
giving you little hints of hey man this
is really hard for me and she wants you
to bring it up but she doesn't know be
honest be honest
and what i'll tell you is it's worth you
being honest
not having secrets telling her how you
really feel
in a respectable dignified way
and seeing if the relationship is strong
enough to hold those that truth
then finding it out ten years down the
road that it's not or seven years down
the road or three years or whatever it
is so yes i think you should have sit
down have that conversation there's not
a lot you can do with her parents other
than to keep showing up and treating
their daughter with dignity and respect
be a person of integrity work really
hard but man there's nothing worse than
some guy that's trying to all butt
kisses
his girlfriend's parent it's just gross
just be be you man be totally 100 you
be a person a character work really hard
give them the impression that you're
somebody worth spending time with their
daughter
the conversations between her daughter
and her and her parents your girlfriend
and her parents because she's got to
grow up